if you're having trouble finding mr or
mrs swipe right it might be time to turn
to matchmaking's ancient roots
literally
because deep in a forest in germany
stands a 600 year old oak tree that has
introduced hundreds of single people
[Music]
it all began around 1890 when the forest
ranger's daughter met a chocolate maker
from leipzig
the father did not approve of the
relationship
they had to find a way to exchange
messages so they used a tree about 300
feet away from the forest ranger's
office
[Music]
a branch had broken off forming a hole
and it was there they put their letters
once her father learned how they were
secretly communicating he finally
approved of their relationship
they married under the tree on june 2nd
1891.
after which the tree became known as
bridegroom's oak
you have the aufkabur
[Music]
[Music]
and people still send letters to the
tree to this day
but can you truly find a life partner
for the price of postage
no one knows better than carl heinz
my name is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
skip swims
[Music]